لك التحيه نحن الان نواكب هذه التغطيه
المستمره لاكثر من اسبوعين هنا في شرق
السودان تحديدا من مدينه بورسودان الذي
التي اصبحت فيها المسارات تتواصل مسارات
الانتقال من السودان الى عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه والعربيه والخليجيه
قبل قليل وصل نحو 153 من رعايه الدول
الاوروبيه الى هذه الباخره التي وصلت مساء
الامس وهي بارجه بحريه حربيه اسبانيه
باسم رينا صوفيا وصلت مساء الامس الى
ميناء بورسودان سيغادر بعد قليل على متنها
نحو 200 من حمله الجنسيات الاوروبيه لعدد
من الدول الاوروبيه هذه البارجه المزوده
بهاليكوبتر وبقوات بحريه خاصه وصلت مساء
الامثله ميناء بورسودان
على قرار البواخر والبوارج والقطع والسفن
الحربيه التي وصلت خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين بنحو اكثر من 30 رحله بحريه وصلت
الى الموانئ السودانيه تحديدا في مينا
بورسودان هذه العمليات مستمره عمليات
اجلاء رعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه حملت
الجوازات من مختلف الدول وصلوا الى هذه
النقطه نقطه مغادره السودان عبر
ميناء بورت سودان كما نتابع الان هذه
البارجس اطبحر بعد قليل وعلى متنها نحو
200 من رعايه الدول الاوروبيه ستتوجه
مباشره الى ميناء جده وبعدها الى عدد من
الوجهات عبر الخطوط الجويه لمختلف الدول
الاوروبيه في سياق متصل عمليات الاجناء
الاجلاء تتواصل نتوقع ايضا خلال الساعات
المقبله قدوم بواخر وبوارج سواء من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او من عدد بعض
وصول اشعارات وطلبات ايضا وصلت الى اللجان
المعنيه هنا في شرق السودان في مدينه
بورسودان لاستكمال اجراءات اجلاء عدد من
رعايه دول العربيه والاجنبيه والافريقيه
في مطار بورسودان الصوره مماثله لما هو
الان في ميناء
بورسودان جسر جوي يوم الامس بدا من قبل
دوله الكويت سيستمر حتى يوم الاثنين
المقبل يحمل نحو 75 طنا من المساعدات
الغذائيه والاغاثيه والدوائيه ايضا قطر
بدات جسرا جويا على ذات المضمار وعلى ذات
الاطار نتحدث عن اكثر من 90 رحله جويه
وصلت الى مطار بورسودان واقلعت من هذا
المطار الذي يعتبر الان النافذه الجويه
الوحيده للسودان وللعالم نحو السودان هنا
في الشرق لايصال المساعدات لاخراج من يطلب
اللجوء ومن يطلب الاجلاء من سودا واكد بان
العمليات مستمره عمليات الخروج عمليات
الاجلاء بتنسيق واشراف مع عدد من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه مع الجيش مع الشرطه مع هيئه
الموانئ البحريه ممتاز
ماذا ايضا عن جدول كذلك السفن التي
تقدم الى بورتسودان سواء خلال ساعات
القريبه القادمه او ايضا حتى خلال هذه
الايام القليله بما ان هناك يعني جدول
واذونات تؤخذ حتى
تمخر هذه السفن باتجاه بورسودان
نعم يعني هذا الامر امر متواصل وامر متصل
تصل المعلومات بصوره مستمره الى اللجنه
المعنيه هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر
الاستقبال طلبات قدوم السفن والبوارج
البحريه والقطع الحربيه الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه المعلومات دائما ما تاتي في
وقت متاخر بعد ان يتم الموافقه على دخول
السفن والقطاع البحريه يتم الاعلام بان
سفينه قادمه من المنطقه المحدده ستصل خلال
الساعه المحدده الى ميناء بورسودان لكن ما
هو مؤكد ما هو مؤمل عليه بان مسار السفن
هو في استمرار بما ان مدينه بورسودان الان
تضم مئات من طالبي المغادره والطالبي
الاجلاء من السودان الى جده الى عدد من
الدول الاوروبيه والعربيه حتما فان السفن
والقطع البحريه ستصل الى مدينه بورسودان
خلال الساعات المق الشيء ايضا الذي نؤكد
عليه بان هذا الميناء منذ ان بدات عمليه
الاجلاء منذ الثاني والعشرين من شهر ابريل
الماضي يستقبل ما بين ثلاث الى ست رحلات
يوميا ودائما تمضي ما بين الرحلتين الى ست
الى خمس رحلات في اليوم هذا يؤكد ايضا على
ان مسار الرحلات مستمر على ان الطلبات
تاتي تباعا الى اللجنه المعنيه بالاجلاء
في المطار وفي الميناء هذا يشير الى ان
الرحلات ستستمر خلال هذا الاسبوع نزار
اخيرا يعني ان كان هناك من معلومه
عدد من تم اجلاؤهم منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
عدد من تم اجلائهم من ميناء بورتسودان ان
كان هناك من رقم محدد او معلوم ومعروف
كذلك
نعم نتوقع التقرير النهائي ولكن المعلومات
التي بحوزاتنا الان وما هو متاح لنا من
مصادرنا
اكثر من 14 الف تم اجلائهم عبر هذا
الميناء الذي تتابعونه الان وعبر هذه
الصور الحصريه لقناه العربيه من الميناء
الاخضر هذا المرسى خرجت منه نحو 30 رحله
بحريه تضم نحو 13 الى 14 الف من طالبي
الاجلاء خلال الساعات الماضيه وخلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين مطار بورسودان على ذات
المنوال وعلى ذات النسق نحو 13 الى 14
ايضا
تم اجلائهم وغادروا عبر المطار او النافذ
الرئيس الان للسودان وللعالم التي تريد ان
تدخل الى السودان عبر مطار بورسودان وهذه
الرحلات في استمرار مطار بورسودان يستقبل
يوميا ما بين ست الى سبع رحلات يوميا هذه
الرحله تصل الى مطار بورسودان باستمرار
تنسق مع الطيران هنا في مدينه بورسودان
وينسقون مع الجيش وينسقون مع لجنه الامن
وبعدها مباشره تحط الطائرات هي طائرات
حربيه
بدات قبل اسبوعين الان نتابع ونشاهد
طائرات لمساعدات من دول العربيه الحديثه
عن قطر الحديث عن الكويت وربما تمضي هذه
الرحلات
لنرى ونشاهد طائرات للاغاثه طائرات من
الامم المتحده الصليب الاحمر كل هذا الان
منفتح بما ان الامين العام او وكيل الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
اشار قبل يومين الى ان مدينه اصبحت نافذه
لتقديم المساعدات فهذا يؤكد ويعني بان شرق
السودان وتحديدا الميناء والمطار سيصبحان
الارضيه والمنفذ الوحيد لاستقبال
المساعدات ولاجلاء من يريد مغادره السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات